after a parent dies like you like your
dad is famous and all yeah did you start
to hear stories about him that you had
never heard before that people call you
and start telling you things and maybe
even things that you don't want to hear
yeah
sure it does happen really what did you
hear that was like you go what the [ __ ]
charles grodden i did a movie with him
this is a few years ago he told me that
once he was directing my dad
in a play
on broadway
and he gave my dad some note
as the director what he should do as an
actor
and
my he said my dad looked at him and said
when somebody talks to me like that it
makes me want to punch them in the face
[Laughter]
and it blew my mind because i never ever
imagined my but he had this deep
deep
like you know anger within him and rage
that he suppressed underneath you know
with the sweetness and that i think
would come out like eventually came out
in his seinfeld character so when your
father died
charles grodin called no he actually
told me that before before he did before
yeah before oh he didn't wait for he
didn't wait for your father to die to
let you know that that's a funny story
yeah yeah yeah uh but i could see that
with charles grodin sometimes you know
he he could be an ornery guy yeah for
sure yeah you know he was definitely i
mean a brilliant brilliant comedic actor
you've directed enough films as an actor
ever said to you listen you say
something to me again i'm going to punch
you in the face have you ever had that
experience not that direct experience
but i have had
actor an actor who was like you know
testing a little bit and you know
and what did you start a fight
no no no i just i finally it forced me
to have to deal with my own issues about
being confrontational and at one point
to say to them like
hey you know when you do that
actually what i said to this actually
when you do that it scares me
and i don't want to be scared when i
come to the set
right
did he have a lack of respect for you
and you no i think he no i i don't i
think he did have respect but i think he
was coming from the place that most
actors are coming from which is fear
that they're going to be bad and it's
not going to be good and i don't know
what was going on in his life on the
outside but you know he was overwhelmed
in that moment and that some actors and
people will
you know the way they react to that is
by lashing out so how much do i have to
pay you to know the name of this actor
who uh you had no because it's gonna
cause me you know i i i won't say it but
but it ended up being a really great
working in retrospect a really great
working relationship um i was happy with
the work it worked out yeah and because
i think i have that very uh my memory is
not good in terms of that like you know
the pain of something you just you let
it go you're the moment you're like this
is like the hardest thing ever and then
you know a year later like well look
what we got out of it